así
en el ejercicio pasado debe de haber
encontrado que o a es igual a r por ccoo
seno de teta primero observa que oprime
a es un triángulo rectángulo entonces
podemos usar senos y cosenos
es el lado adyacente a theta lo cual
significa que es igual a r por coseno de
teta y de la misma forma a pepe prima es
igual a r por seno de teta ahora
necesitamos demostrar que de pp prima a
es el ángulo fi y esto es porque hay
algunos triángulos similares por ahí en
particular este triángulo y este otro
triángulo son similares y podemos ver
que eso es cierto porque este ángulo es
igual a este ángulo como lo prueba el
teorema de los ángulos opuestos por el
vértice observa también que este ángulo
tiene 90 grados
entonces estos triángulos tienen dos
ángulos iguales lo cual implica que el
tercer ángulo también tiene que ser
igual porque la suma de los tres ángulos
del triángulo tiene que ser igual a 180
por lo tanto se ve prima a es igual a fi
y ahora sí ya estamos listos una de las
cosas que estamos buscando es esta
distancia o se porque esa es x prima
como observamos anteriormente o se es
igual a v - bc entonces x prima es igual
a v - bc y como veces es igual a d
podemos escribirlo como x prima es igual
a v menos a de pero que es de ese lado
adyacente a phil entonces el coste no de
fi es igual a o b / a&a y sabemos que o
a es igual a r por el coche no beteta
así es que josé no de fi es igual a v
/ r por coseno de teta por lo que es
igual a r por coseno dt está por coseno
de fi ok v es igual a r por coseno de
fib por coseno beteta pero nosotros
sabemos que r por coseno de fi es igual
a x así es que v es igual a x por coseno
dt está bueno y ahora cuánto es a d
pues ade es el lado opuesto a fi en el
triángulo de prima a entonces seno de fi
es igual a a de entre a prima pero
sabemos que adapté prima es igual a r
porsche no detecta si es que el seno de
fi es igual a ade / r por seno de teta y
entonces a d es igual a r porsche no
detecta por seno de fi pero eso lo
podemos reacomodar como r por seno de fi
porsche no detecta porque sabemos que r
por seno de fi es así es que ade es
igual hay por seno dt está muy bien eso
lo que significa es que x prima es igual
a x por coseno beteta menos de porsche
no detecta bueno ya vamos a la mitad
ahora sólo nos falta averiguar cuánto es
de prima cp prima es igual a de prima
pero también podemos escribir que sé
prima es igual a de prima
más ave
dp prima es el lado adyacente a fin
entonces el coseno de fi es igual a dp
prima / ap prima pero ap prima es igual
a r por seno de teta entonces coseno de
teta es igual a de pep prima entre r por
seno de teta y de pep prime es igual a r
por seno de teta por coseno de fi lo
cual es igual a x por seno de eta ahora
abre es el lado opuesto de fi entonces
seno de fi es igual a ave entre o a 0
es igual a r por coseno de teta entonces
seno de fi es igual a ave entre r por
coseno beteta y así a b es igual a r por
seno de fi por ccoo seno de teta pero r
porsche no ve es igual hay entonces ave
es igual a por coseno beteta y juntando
todas estas cosas nos queda que prima es
igual a equis
porsche no detecta más porque seno de
teta y listo lo logramos
x prima es igual a x por coseno beteta
menos por seno de teta y que prima es
igual a x por seno de teta más por
coseno de teta te quedaste hasta el
final y ya viste esta fórmula súper
poderosa y súper útil ya sea que estés
haciendo gráficos por computadora o
construyendo puentes o triangulando
posiciones vas a ver que estas fórmulas
aparecen una y otra vez en todos lados
usa el próximo ejercicio para practicar
con ellas